[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ce plateau
celui de face aux territoires sur
tv5monde en direct avec nos partenaires
nos partenaires de ouest france de nice
matin de france antilles du centre
france la montagne et de 20 minutes vous
pouvez regarder cette émission en direct
ou en repli sur les sites internet de
ces titres m'ont invité ce matin c'est
un invité un peu particulier dans cette
période de guerre en ukraine c'est
l'ambassadeur de france en ukraine vadim
omeltchenko bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous dans cette émission ce
matin je sais que vous êtes peu présent
dans les médias vous avez on imagine un
emploi du temps très compliqué en ce
moment donc doublement merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau en direct ce matin
alors la guerre en ukraine c'est moscou
qui annonce un cessez le feu pour
aujourd'hui jeudi l'elysée reste très
prudent a fait savoir que ce n'est pas
la première fois que la russie fait ce
type d' annonce vous y croyez vous
aujourd'hui à ce cessez-le-feu à mario
paul
bonjour tout le monde je vous remercie
beaucoup de cette invitation je suis
ravi d'être chez vous car je suis
inspecteur fidèles de votre émission et
je suis ravi de prendre part à cette
émission parce qu'il a toujours cette
dimension humaine à ce qui concerne
votre question nous aussi nous serons
très prudents à l'égard de ses
déclarations au motion
déclaration a déjà été fait il ya
quelques jours
concernant le retrait des troupes
notamment mais nous n'avons pas observé
sur le terrain et nous sommes
extrêmement prudents car il n'est pas à
exclure
il s'agit d'une pause
jeux tactiques
afin de regrouper les forces et de
préparer une nouvelle attaque car sur la
direction qui ont été déclarées
donc et le self de feu et les retraits
des troupes c'est là où ils ont connu
des grandes pertes vous êtes un proche
du président volodymyr zelensky voulu
parler
combien de fois par semaine comment se
passent les contacts et comment va-t-il
pouvez vous nous donner de ses nouvelles
nous sommes aussi déçus ont connu
après deux à trois fois par semaine
j'apprends par les réunions qu'il donne
organise sur différents sujets
général cela se passe la nuit le bodo
bien ce nouveau genre de près de minuit
à vrai dire je ne sais pas où il puise
ses forces
mais il retient tout ce qui reste en
deçà des taux piste lors des réunions
ils discutent à part aux ambassadeurs je
vois qu'il retient à les détails
concernant chaque paie les objectifs qui
ont été fixés par rapport à ce pays et
en même temps
si riche l'état dirige le front la
guerre
je ne sais pas où il prend ses forces
car n'y a que vingt quatre heures dans
la journée c'est vadim omeltchenko
l'ambassadeur d'ukraine en france qui
est notre invité ce matin sur tv5monde
en direct dans un instant
françois-xavier le franc de ouest france
sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier l'offrant vous
avez le rédacteur en chef du plus grand
quotidien en langue française au monde
nous allons parler donc avec
l'ambassadeur tout d'abord du quotidien
d'un ambassadeur dans un pays en guerre
bonjour monsieur l'ambassadeur vous êtes
le l'ambassadeur en france d'un pays en
guerre d'un pays qui souffrent quel est
votre rôle et celui de vos équipes quel
est le rôle d ambassadeur d'ukraine dans
les pays occidentaux en ce moment ces
jours ci alors que votre pays et emploie
en plaques à eau
un jour un rôle
de l'ambassadeur
général est d'abord de représenter son
président ont dit que
l'ambassadeur est un alter ego du
président de même
maintenant je représente tout d'abord
notre président et notre pécule donnons
seulement rôle et 2,8 sur nos portes et
aux produits transmettre notre position
à l'égard des événements qui se
déroulent aujourd'hui mon rôle est de
contact avec les autorités françaises un
premier lieu nos opérations pasqua
m'embrouille gbowee que davantage
aujourd'hui
charge de travail
dépasse le temps de ce pays donc c'est
d'abord ce que c'est les réfugiés
assurer la logistique ce qui concerne
l'aide humanitaire c'est la
communication avec les mass médias
la commission à
la défense brooklyn
d'autres domaines l'éducation par
exemple aujourd'hui nous aurons une
rencontre avec ministre l'éducation de
français et c'est
l'invasion russe en ukraine la guerre
provoquée par les russes a provoqué
beaucoup de réactions partout dans le
monde et notamment en france et dans
tous les territoires français beaucoup
de françaises et de français se
mobilisent pour venir en aide pour
accueillir des réfugiés pour recueillir
des dons pour apporter une aide
matérielle beaucoup se projette vers la
frontière entre la pologne et d'ukraine
justement pour venir aider est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que la réaction
est à la hauteur est à la hauteur de ce
que vous attendez
nous attendions pas à une telle réaction
cette réaction a dépassé toutes nos
attentes se
protège c'est une réaction puissante
nous ne nous attendions pas à ce que
monde réagisse ainsi que l'ambassadeur
en france je dirais que le peuple
français déploient
des trésors de solidarité d'autres
organisations nous voyons le soutien
d'un haut niveau de l'état mais aussi
peut-être en premier lieu de la part du
peuple français voyons comment les
villes françaises s'organise
contre l'aide humanitaire comment les
gens accueillent les réfugiés chez eux
donc j'ai toujours dit je le dis
aujourd'hui que le peuple français est
un peu plus au grand coeur alors que ce
qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez dire à
tous ces gens là de quoi avez vous
besoin beaucoup de gens ont envie de
donner envie d'agir de quoi avez vous
besoin et je complète la question par ou
faut-il donner
à qui pour que cet argent ou ceux où
tous ses biens arrive à destination
c'est souvent un problème
mais je suis je vais ramasser de votre
question me moque de ceux qui souhaitent
apporter une aide quelle qu'elle soit
s'adresser au
centre crise du ministère des affaires
étrangères français
corps dodu tous ces besoins il ya donc
nous demandent nos besoins il ya les
comptes bancaires de verser de l'argent
et associations des bénévoles du travail
l'ambassade des vents la masa devant le
centre anti crise donc tous ceux qui
souhaitent aider pourront trouver tous
les renseignements nécessaires voilà on
fera pas c'est d'ailleurs cette adresse
sur l'écran régulièrement dans cette
émission c'est donc vadim omeltchenko
l'ambassadeur d'ukraine en france qui
est notre invité ce matin en direct dans
face au territoire monsieur
l'ambassadeur chaunu qui est dessinateur
collaborateur de ouest france à une
question c'est la tradition de cette
émission à vous poser sous forme de
dessin vous allez voir il s'agit de
votre président
comparaison n'est pas raison mais force
est de constater qu'il y a en la
personne volodymyr et linski du
churchill mais aussi du de gaulle
surtout depuis la libération d'hier pin
la question que je pose
vladimir poutine par son agression
n'at-il pas fait entrer l'ukraine et son
peuple par la grande porte de l'histoire
non sans motta chivu
micro de monchy ce que nous constatons
il a essayé de diviser l'europe au
contraire l'europe série il a essayé de
diviser le cren de la détruire il a au
contraire réussi les ukrainiens il a
essayé de détruire notre esprit au
contraire notre esprit c'est un jour
davantage et c'est en quelque sorte un
réseau on n'est pas dire grâce à un
changement il ya beaucoup d'empathie
une passion pour le cren les gens ne
commence mieux maintenant selon une
autre peuple et tout le monde est
conscient que nous sommes comptables
européennes tout le monde comprend que
nous défendons nous nous défendons
contre l'agression non seulement nous
mêmes mais aussi l'europe
une question concernant votre président
le président et l'ins qui on le
connaissait peu finalement parce qu'il
n'avait pas beaucoup de passes et
politique il avait une autre vie avant
et aujourd'hui son courage est saluée
unanimement dans le monde comment
expliquer l'ampleur politique qu'a pris
cet homme qui est à la tête d'un état
qui souffrent et qui a une énergie
incroyable nous le disions tout à
l'heure comment expliquer la dimension
qu'a pris cet homme qui n'avait pas une
longue vie politique derrière lui
dans une situation extrême nord les gens
se révèlent chaque personne se montre à
son vrai jour certains se montrent comme
des troncs d'autres devient le courageux
question se montre noble et courageux et
un autre très rare dans les solutions
extrêmes et c'est là qu'on n'ouvre qu'on
montre son vrai visage
tout d'abord il a toujours été sincère
je me suis venu sur cette sincérité les
gens j voter pour lui
pour un homme on tient le sincère et
lorsque la situation
secret de cette manière à l'ukraine et
le chien comporter d'abord comme un
homme sincère il a toujours souligné go
que l'éducation je reçu de ses parents
était important ce sont les parents qui
ont
élevé en lui c'est ce trait de caractère
et la façon dont ils servent les
montrent qu'à l'intérieur de lui cette
norme courageux et qui est prête à
répondre à tous les défis et lefranc la
une de ouest france la une de l'ouest
france consacré au prix de l'énergie à
la guerre en ukraine et aussi au sommet
vendredi donc demain le sommet entre
l'union européenne et la chine est bien
évidemment la question ukrainienne
l'agression de l'ukraine par lettre par
la russie sera au coeur des discussions
monsieur l'ambassadeur vous restez avec
nous bien sûr dans un instant denis
carot va nous rejoindre et ce cas un
esprit ukrainien un esprit particulier
et craignant comme profile et le front
le disait le monde regarde l'ukraine de
manière différente est ce qu'un esprit
ukrainien très très rapidement
dos c'est pas je suis pris du monde le
voit aujourd'hui le monde entier je
pense que vous aussi à notre esprit
est dans nos gènes financier vous savez
vous à notre insu le monde entier en
battant le champion souvent il y as
ennemis nous vous donnons à notre corps
et notre âme pour d'autres c'est ça vous
vous plaignez au japon sont deux raids à
sac les nôtres cornes pour la liberté
denis carot dans un instant de nice
matin sur ce plateau merci françois des
villes offrant
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot vous êtes le
directeur des rédactions du groupe nice
matin qui accuse bien sûr var matin et
monaco matin merci d'être avec nous dans
un instant vous allez interviewer à mes
côtés l'ambassadeur d'ukraine en france
vadim omeltchenko mais tout de suite
nous partons au loin d'ici à 8000 km
justement que peut faire la france des
8000 kilomètres qui est à 8000 km pour
l'ukraine et bien c'est la question de
cyril bouty et le directeur éditorial de
france antilles notre partenaire ou
écoute depuis fort de france bonjour
monsieur l'ambassadeur chez nous aux
antilles en guyane la communauté
ukrainienne n'est pas très importante
bien entendu cependant un certain nombre
d'actions tente de se mettre en place
sans solidarité solidarité qui est
difficile à exercer puisque nous sommes
à huit mille kilomètres de l'europe
selon vous quelles actions à distance
nos territoires des antilles et la
guyane pourrait mener en soutien au
peuple ukrainien
on peut reprocher aujourd'hui d'abord je
vous remercie beaucoup avoir ma chance
je te l'homme se vouer aux habitants
cette manifestation de solidarité
est un jour parce que votre je voudrais
vous dire
[Musique]
mobile aux uns et aux autres
cette mobilisation se le désir d'aider
ailleurs il y a d'abord donc le site de
l'ambassade ukrainienne du consulat
ukrainiens sont lestés nos besoins il ya
les informations dans le centre anti
crise de 1100 affaires étrangères
français il ya l'association des villes
françaises dirigées par
maire de la ville de cannes et là aussi
il ya une grande auto organisation de
collecte notamment de l'aide de
l'acheminement de questions de
logistique il y a plusieurs axes qui
pourraient être utilisés pour apporter
une aide alcon pour laquelle nous sommes
très reconnaissants denis carot monsieur
l'ambassadeur bonjour un bâtiment du
comité international de la croix rouge a
été la cible de bombardements russes
hier à marioupol est-ce que vous avez
des informations sur cette attaque et
sur ses conséquences
j'ai c'est ce qui a été publié dans les
mass médias donc je ne connais rien
davantage en fait je sais qu'il ya une
attaque ça ne nous étonne pas car mario
paul vous souvenez y est
le site où est indiqué en grandes
lettres enfants théâtre d'opéra qui est
servait d'abri
aérien plusieurs milliers de personnes
se s'étaient abrités là bas à l'usagé
des femmes et les enfants
essentiellement
bombardé beaucoup pour éviter justement
de bombarder ce
bâtiment il y avait des deux côtés en
grandes lettres écrit enfants en russe
les expertises que celui qui a bombardé
ce bâtiment ne peut pas mener pas voir
ces inscriptions est né à moi ce
bâtiment a été bombardée parlera parmi
ces une croisière on essaie toujours
toujours pas combien de victimes sont à
déplorer et donc ni les inscriptions ni
la croix-rouge n'arrête les barbares la
croix rouge fait l'objet d'une campagne
de dénigrement sur les réseaux sociaux
accusés d'avoir pris part à l'évacuation
forcée de civils vers vers la russie ces
accusations sont injustifiées
e
je ne justifie aucune attaque mais
d'expérience j'ai eu à deux reprises
l'occasion de discuter avec leurs
besoins de csr ces deux dernières
semaines tout d'abord avec le
responsable de la 6è république
française ensuite le bureau central de
la croix rouge internationale et mon
impression je vous le dis brièvement
donc la teneur de notre dialogue poser
la question pourquoi je ne voyons pas
près des villes assiégées puisque tout
un chacun nous avons été élevés de
l'enfance
sur le fait que la croix rouge est
présente là où il ya besoin là où il ya
la guerre la délégation est
catastrophique et c'est pour cela que la
croix-rouge bénéficier d'une immunité
lui permet d'agir dans les situations où
les deux parties ne peuvent pas agir est
donc j'ai posé la question pourquoi
n'allez pas danser en liant n'organisait
pas le couloir humanitaire dans les
villes des assiégés par exemple et la
réponse était puisque la russie ne
reconnaît pas notre immunité et nous
avons tous peur qui nous attachent pas
je dis très bien où est votre
déclaration publique à ce sujet pourquoi
vous ne glisse pas au monde entier que
la russie ne reconnaît pas à votre
immunité il n'y a pas eu de déclaration
publique eu lieu deuxième aspect nous
avons discuté c'est la transparence
vous savez que cette organisation
oddo vise à donner une grande confiance
à travers le monde
des fonds importants destinés à l'aide
humanitaire ont été versés à la
croix-rouge pouvoir nous avons demandé
une transparence à vrai dire nous ne
voyons toujours pas ou pas toujours
ouvrons cette à ces sommes les alpes
maritimes sont le premier département
d'accueil pour les réfugiés nice a mis
en place un centre régional d'accueil
marseille
on voit la mise en place l'aménagement
d'un ferry qui va accueillir mille 600
réfugiés est ce que la france est
suffisamment à la hauteur en termes
d'accueil des réfugiés
j'ai déjà dit la france est proactive
nous nous y attendions pas
bougé je parlais déjà des vols des
merdes mère de marcel demers de cannes
qui s'organise qui s'auto organisent
organise la logistique depuis marseille
déjà bien établi jusqu'en pologne donc
je ne peux que remercier
le peuple français
qui peuplent pour leurs actions
proactives près de trente mille réfugiés
sont arrivés en france est ce qu'ils
seront nombreux à y rester
mais je suis certain que je ne suis pas
beaucoup un restaurant parce que tous
ces gens rêvent de rentrer dans l'arène
et nous espérons que dès que la paix
reviendra la majorité écrasante de ces
gens retournera dans leur maison
denis carot la une de nice matin
aujourd'hui alors la une de nice matin
un sujet qui peut paraître dérisoire
dans le contexte l'ouverture dans 40
jours d'ikea à nice une ouverture qui
est attendu depuis depuis dix ans une
question peut-être sur les oligarques
russes qui sont sur la côte d'azur
certains dit on
sont assez défavorable à l'action de
vladimir poutine
cette entrée en guerre vous en entendez
parler vous même l'ambassadeur d'ukraine
en france de cette réaction
timorés plutôt froide des oligarques
face à cette guerre
aux pêcheurs choo
pour l'instant j'ai entendu de la part
de certains oligarques les plaintes du
fait que leurs comptes sont arrêtés
qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent pour vivre
pour
employer une femme de ménage donc c'est
le seul regret qu'ils expriment face à à
la mort des enfants à la destruction des
villes c'est la seule réaction ils
disent mais nous n'y sommes pour rien
nous ne pouvons pas nous pouvons rien
faire danser ça cette réaction que je le
vois constaté il savait les oligarques
russes une chose ne sont que des
bénéficiaires du régime russe le pouvoir
en russie et des tables et de telle
manière que si le jean le gall
énormément d'argent cela en effet que
sur l'autorisation personnel de poutine
donc ses larmes de crocodile ne nous
impressionne pas
vadim omeltchenko qui est le
l'ambassadeur d'ukraine en france est
notre invité ce matin merci denis carot
dans un instant armelle le goff du
journal 20 minutes et sur ce plateau
[Musique]
armelle le goff l'état des lieux sur le
terrain aujourd'hui en ukraine oui sur
le front militaire les forces
ukrainiennes ont en fait surpris tout le
monde par leur capacité de résistance
face à des forces russes que tout le
monde pensait indestructible à votre
avis à quoi qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence
nous proposons tout d'abord
l'armée et craignent un défendre sa
maison et sa terre
vous savez que cette attaque de la
russie
il parle aujourd'hui
cette attaque a été basée sur des
informations fausses et
de nombreuses années elle dépensé de
l'argent
en informé en continu et les directions
de la russie que le prénom est divisée
que nation ukrainienne n'existe pas que
dès qu elles seules la russe mettra en
janvier en ukraine qui seraient
accueillis avec des fleurs il y à des
régions russophones cetera et cetera
donc ils ont désinformées y compris leur
propre direction leurs propres
dirigeants et l'argent comme d'habitude
en russie a été volé
il donc la première chose qu'elle devait
faire face c'est le peuple craignant
qu'ils existent à mieux hume qui
y compris sa partie russophone
légende et l'histoire temporairement
occupée par les russes aujourd'hui les
gens continuent à manifester et en
langue russe leur dire rentrez chez vous
c'est notre maison c'est le crédit cible
on a pu voir aussi que les forces
craignait n'avait eu l'appui d'outils
technologiques comme par exemple les
drones interstellar d'elon musk est ce
que par exemple ces technologies qui ont
été mises à disposition en l'occurrence
d'elon musk et aussi éventuellement des
forces militaires européennes ont pu
faire la différence aussi sur le terrain
[Musique]
nous avons en effet reçu peut-être moins
que ce que nous désirions
mais nous avons reçu de l'armement
technologique
que nous utilisons de manière efficace
les experts militaires sont absolument
enchanté de l'efficacité de ces armes
par exemple el hadj avaline donc armes
anti-char
presse britannique pour baptiser que les
analystes ont donc estimé qu'il y avait
112 tir et sans réussir ont été
efficaces
toucher leur cible donc les occidentaux
eux-mêmes sont étonnés et ravis de voir
que cette arme c'est aussi efficace
al'inverse ils sont plus que les forces
russes utilisent des armes interdites
par les conventions internationales vous
confirmer par exemple l'utilisation de
bombes à sous-munitions
par les forces russes
c'est déjà un fait établi et j'utilise
larmes balistique les
termes en barriques de notre
augmentation
nous avons des exemples de bombes à
phosphore toutes ces armes sont
interdites par les conventions
internationales chaud
vous savez qu'elle a
il ya déjà une
instruction ouverte pour les crimes
contre l'humanité et les cinq acteurs de
la haie et les enquêteurs ukrainiens
sont en train de collecter les faits à
chaque endroit où cette arme à être ces
armes ont été utilisées sur les terrains
militaires encore les forces russes en
début de semaine ont dit qu elle ce
qu'elle ne visait plus kiev et qu'elle
comptait se replier vers l'est
les renseignements américains disent
avoir des doutes sur ces affirmations
est ce que vous aussi c'est des doutes
qui vous rend monte du terrain depuis
l'ukraine le fait que effectivement les
forces russes se replient vers l'est
nous sommes tout à fait
dans une position nous avons fait
d'autres nous ne croyons pas dans ces
informations pour l'instant nous ne
constatons pas de mouvement en direction
de désescalade
nous ne croyons pas aux déclarations
nous croyons au fait est ce que vladimir
poutine
pourra-t-il être un interlocuteur
acceptable dans le futur immédiat pour
l'ukraine
parliez il y a un instant de la manière
dont il a sans doute été désinformés par
c'est sa propre armée ses propres
services de renseignement est-ce que ça
le dédouane d'être totalement
cramé à vos yeux
au poche tout d'abord
il n'a pas être informé parce que il a
créé une atmosphère où tout le monde a
peur de lui dire la vérité
quelle qu'elle soit il vous le voyez
bien la russie est un empire où la
vérité est interdite simplement guerre
commencée le mans guerre peut entraîner
des poursuites pénales nous voyons que
les gens peu risqué 15 ans de prison
pour le fait de prononcer le mot guerre
qui a créé cette situation c'est poutine
donc dire qu'il n'a pas été informé
qu'il serait gentil il met juste mal
informés ce n'est pas tout à fait ce
n'est pas tout à fait juste voir ce
n'est pas juste du tout en ce qui
concerne le fait peut-on le considérer
comme un interlocuteur lui serrer la
main j'ai de grands doutes quant au fait
qu'un leader mondial elle voudrait
serrer la main à un jeune homme
responsable de la mort de beaucoup de
gens et personnes âgées pour le
président de lenski pour le gouvernement
ukrainien dans les semaines immédiate
qui arrive si une négociation s'ouvre et
est ce que vladimir poutine pour être
l'homme de cette négociation face à vous
nous sommes prêts à des pourparlers avec
qui que ce soit qui représente la russie
qui peut influencer et arrêter cette
guerre en même temps
nous avons de grands doutes vous voyez
bien comment elle discute avec les gens
autour d'une table et qui fait 12 mètres
de long il est difficile de voir comment
pourrait-il se présenter aux pourparlers
arman goff les forces russes ont accusé
semble-t-il de lourdes pertes sur le
terrain pertes humaines parmi les
soldats qui étaient déployés quels sont
les chiffres que vous avez aujourd'hui
on sent une pièce en marché de ces
derniers temps
de chiffres correspondent parfaitement
pratiquement mort avec les chiffres de
nos partenaires de renseignements
américains et britanniques israélien
france est d'ailleurs aussi
on parle de près de 17 milliards morts
et de près de quarante mille blessés
lourds sachant qu'en russie les chiffres
sont autour de 2000 soldats décédés
mais selon les informations
d'un certain gilles on enterre ci mais
tellement entre deux cents et 40 de 400
personnes dont des soldats vêtus
directement en contact avec les services
secrets américains
ils vous ont bien informés ils
continuent de le faire
bien évidemment de travaillons avec tous
nos partenaires nous ont pas seulement
avec les américains armelle le goff
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
la une de 20minutes il ya une de 20
minutes c'est un reportage à tallinn en
estonie où la situation en ukraine
provoque des inquiétudes et des tensions
merci al mail le goff directrice de la
rédaction de 20 minutes dans un instant
sylvia garcia de tv5monde rédactrice en
chef adjointe et sur ce plateau avec
[Musique]
bonjour sylvia garcia dans un instant
nous allons parler avec vous et avec
vadim omeltchenko l'ambassadeur
d'ukraine en france 2 comment sortir de
cette guerre mais tout de suite
rejoignant antoine busnel du bercy
républicain monsieur l'ambassadeur du
groupe centre france la montagne qui est
partenaire de cette émission face aux
territoires il a une question à vous
poser depuis bourges une question oppose
des pourparlers en cours
vadim omeltchenko monsieur l'ambassadeur
bonjour des pourparlers ont commencé en
ce début de semaine en turquie des
délégations ukrainiennes et russes se
retrouvent au même endroit pour échanger
essayer de mettre fin à la guerre
quelles sont les principales attentes de
l'ukraine à l'occasion de ces
discussions à istanbul pensez vous que
votre pays puisse retrouver
l'intégralité de ses frontières airs
tout et vous sérieusement une situation
à la coréenne avec un pays finalement
divisé en deux
unités territoriales de l'ukraine n'est
pas un objet de discussion et ne se
discute pas
me concerne l'espoir entre la position
de l'ukraine au cours de ces pourparlers
je conseillerais de loudes de regarder
un accès
direct l'interview du président alain ce
qui donné il ya quelques jours en mass
médias d'opposition russe où il a
répondu de manière très détaillée
sur les quais la position de l'ukraine
au cours de ces pourparlers
il ya
deux aspects qui ont été abordés donc
comment être les questions ukrainienne
se présentent ces pourparlers bussereau
a déclaré ne rien voir de prometteurs
dans les pourparlers après les avoir
qualifié la veille de significatif
comment vous expliquer cette volte face
d'abord ils disent toujours que qu'ils
ne comprennent pas les pourparlers
au contraire
après cette dernière pour parler nous
voyons que
commence à
sourire et à discuter de manière plus
sérieuse certaines questions donc juste
ces pourparlers est ce qu'un moule et je
n'ai pas entendu que dire que le dernier
pour parler qu'il n'y a pas d'avancée
donc au contraire l'exigence de la
russie c'est un statut neutre de
l'ukraine qui a étudié par le camp
ukrainien est ce que ça ne reviendrai
pas mettre l'ukraine sous tutelle
en aucun cas
ni comment se présente la neutralité
d'un autre vision tout d'abord je cite
le président alain ce qui lie en tant
que garant de la constitution de
l'ukraine quelles sont les possibilités
qui s'offre à moi la première
possibilité si je suis disposé à
discuter de neutralité de l'ukraine je
suis prête à le discuter mais
notre opinion doit refléter l'opinion de
la société craignait j'ai deux
possibilités soit le référendum soit le
changement de la position
constitutionnelle et non termini mom
deux sessions du parlement ukrainien il
aurait fait le faire un dogme selon la
législation internationale ne peut être
reconnu légitime que
sur le territoire de l'ukraine est tout
autre pays il n'y a pas de forces
militaires étrangères ou d'y monter
armes et donc la condition eu de
discussions dans neutralité c'est
d'abord le retrait des troupes russes
hors des frontières de le crâne c'est
une condition préalable vous demandez
aussi à ce que des puissances étrangères
garantissent la sécurité de l'ukraine
les états unis la chine la france la
grande-bretagne mais aussi la turquie
l'allemagne la pologne israël dans tous
ses contacts quel lien y at il
aujourd'hui quels contacts at-il entre
pékin et kiev
je te goures jeunes au logement de
l'idée de neutralité comme vous savez
nous avons déjà eu cette expérience
douloureuse avec le meneur d'hommes de
budapest qui a été signée nous avons
renoncé aux armes nucléaires et ensuite
nous on s'est dit que en fait il n'y a
jamais eu de garanties et c'est donc
aujourd'hui si nous discutons
sérieusement de cette question nous
voulons créer un système de garantie
garantie sérieuse
ces décisions soient à pic à dopter par
les parlements de ces pays
l'idée consiste à dire que les pays
garants du et membre du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu et les pays qui sont
désireux de devenir garengeot de se
joindre
à ce processus en ce qui concerne la
chine nous discutons avec la chine
si on a commencé à s que la chine est
prête à tenir garant elle devrait y
avoir des négociations séparées de long
terme sur le dombass sur la crimée est
ce que dans l'idée de négociations pour
sortir de la guerre l'ukraine pourrait
renoncer à ces territoires
est-ce que l'ukraine pourrait renoncer à
ces territoires réponses courtes ce
dans cette très nette jamais le crâne ne
renoncera à ses territoires quand il
s'agit des territoires d'un état
souverain garcia merci monsieur
l'ambassadeur vadim omeltchenko vous
êtes grand père depuis quelques jours
votre petit fils est né à kiev au moment
où qu'elles étaient quasi bombardé en
tout cas que la guerre des marais
comment va-t-il il a pu rentrer en
france
votre petit fils
je vous remercie pour d'une gestion en
effet me dont l'ojectif istance attendu
revenu m et deux jours avant le début de
la guerre accueillez
vous
imaginez
la fin le bébé de deux jours se cacher
avec sa mère dans une cave sanabria et
c'était dur
réussi à les faire venir en france est
actuellement ma belle-fille avec le bébé
là alors que monfils resté en ukraine
vous êtes un escrimeur
et vous avez tout jeune aimer ce sport
grâce à un film français la tulipe noire
avec alain delon vous êtes un admirateur
de l'acteur français vous aimez aussi le
film notre histoire de bertrand blier
beaucoup d'ukrainiens 7 cet attrait pour
la france ça explique aussi ce set cet
engouement réciproque de nos deux pays
l'un pour l'autre
tout à fait je vous remercie pour cette
question et
l'évocation de cette expérience en effet
lorsque j'avais 7 ans
ma maman m'a amenée voir un film chinois
et après elle m'a mené par la main à a
donc faire de l'escrimé où je suis resté
dix ans
et à pratiquer ce sport
et cela à l'époque soviétique il y avait
le rideau de fer
imaginions la france
grâce au cinéma en premier lieu les
visages
du cinéma français et un de ces visages
étaient alain delon
est évident que ce tube
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la raison d'ailleurs
pour laquelle quand vous savez le centre
culturel ukrainiens se trouve au 22
avenue de messine est natel particuliers
qui ont autrefois appartenait à alain
delon nous avons créé une pièce en 1h02
d'alain delon et 7,1 à une signe de
reconnaissance de la part de l'état
ukrainien de la part du peuple ukrainien
la reconnaissance de l'apport d'alain
delon dans la culture universelle
c'est un petit geste modeste mais nous
avons décidé de le faire et d'ailleurs
avant de créer cette salle
j'ai
obtenu l'accord du président céline
stick soutenu chaleureusement cette idée
est sûre donc ces salles existent déjà
et nous attendons la visite de
d'allendale on chez non justement le
président zelensky était-il pris
suffisamment au sérieux et est ce que
cette guerre aurait eu lieu au monsieur
l'ambassadeur si on avait entendu mieux
et plus fort le président et l'aide ce
qui
vous savez cela fait de nombreuses
années qu'on nous entende est pas
on ne nous a pas entendus des pilules
début de l'occupation de la crimée le
président de lenski a
adapté une position et puissante plus
active
et sa position et de dire que si nous
faisons partie de la famille européenne
pourquoi nous tenons des pis si
longtemps devant la porte
merci vadim omeltchenko ambassadeur
d'ukraine en france d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin sur tv5 monde on imagine
votre emploi du temps vous avez à faire
et nous eh bien nous rendre l'antenne l
émission on continue sur tv5 monde on se
retrouve jeudi prochain même heure à
9h30 en direct au revoir à tous et merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mardi